[موسيقى]
البرد ياتينا مستورا و ياتينا على شكل
موجات تهب علينا بين انن واخر وله بدايه
وشده ونهايه فبدايته مع موسم اصفري
والعامه يسمونه برد الوسم خلال شهر سبتمبر
توقعوا البرد في اوله وتلقوه في اخره فانه
يعمل في الاجساد كعمله في الاشجار فاوله
محرق واخره مورق وشده البرد برد الازيرك
بل النجمه الثالث من نجوم المربعانيه واول
الشرطه اواخر شهر ديسمبر واول شهر يناير
والعامه يسمونه برد جراند تاسع وقالوا
جراند تاسع بارد لاسع واخر موجات البرد
برد الحميمين يا ربنا يا رحيمكفينا برد
الحميمين والعرب القدماء يسمونه برد
الحسوم وهو البرد الذي اهلك الله به قوم
عاد سخرها عليهم سبع ليالي وثمانيه ايام
حسوما فترى القوم فيها سرعا كانهم اعجاز
نخل
خاويه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والايام القادمه سنعيش فيها ابرد ايام
السنه برد المربعانيه وبارد الشبط بارد
المربعانيه بردا الرطب والشبط جاف تشرين
اول وتشرين ثاني وهلا الاولين الله يرحمهم
بالشام يقولون بردت تشارين احد من ضرب
السكاكين
[موسيقى]